all right we are live on the world wide
web i'm dave rubin it is a friday which
means it's time for another friday round
table panel extravaganza and joining me
are the founder of rebel news ezra
levant the host of the news and why it
matters on blaze tv sarah gonzalez and
an award-winning actor and the director
of the new movie capital punishment nick
cearcy ezra sarah nick welcome to the
reuben report
thank you
nice to be here i like having a panel
with all guests with four letters in
their first names makes it nice and easy
for me
wait sarah you got an h in there or no
there's no h in there right absolutely
not that's no unnecessary silent h no
because that would have really screwed
us up right at the top uh all right i am
uh happy to have you guys here nick i
cannot believe this is your first time
on the show ezra and sarah are old
reuben report veterans uh but the topics
that we're going to be covering today
nick are right up your alley they're
right up all of your alleys actually
mainly we're going to cover
a crazy week in censorship uh mostly
from big tech but it's really coming
from sort of this globalist
international government whatever you
want to call it at this point uh that's
the direction we're going in today real
quick let me talk to you guys about
tommy john and then we will get to it uh
is the summer heat melting your ice
cubes stay frosty where it counts in
brand new tommy john underwear with
dozens of comfort innovations tommy john
will keep you looking and feeling cool
all season long from lounging at home to
summertime fun and with over 17 million
pairs sold people love their tommy john
underwear and loungewear that's why
tommy john doesn't have just customers
they have fanatics i love wearing my
tommy john underwear which i'm wearing
right now when i take clyde on a hot
walk in a humid day in miami tommy don
doesn't just make you feel cooler you
actually are cooler stay up to seven
degrees cooler than cotton in tommy
john's apollo underwear plus there's no
risk because you're covered with tommy
john's best pair you'll ever wear or
it's free guarantee
shop tommyjohn.com ruben right now for
20 off your first order get 20 off your
first order at tommyjohn.com
reuben and now back to me should i ask
any of you guys what kind of underwear
you're wearing before we start
tommy john actually
excellent i can't remember i've had it
on for so long i don't remember what it
was
nick reporting live from the bunker okay
here we go guys so look it was a crazy
week obviously with censorship and i as
i said several times this week i don't
like when i am in the news because i'd
rather talk about the things going on
but i sort of was in the news this week
as a matter of fact i was i think at one
point uh the number one trend on twitter
uh because of this ridiculous suspension
uh people know about it already but ben
shapiro summed up what happened quite
well in a tweet and then ben didn't get
suspended which was bizarre ben said on
twitter reuben report has now been
suspended for posting news about jordan
peterson's suspension all because we are
not allowed to mention that up until
five minutes ago elliott paige who is
very very very male
was a female actress named ellen page
uh
well where should we start here you know
what uh sarah i feel like you've either
been banned on twitter before or you've
at least been suspended or punished one
way or another um should i be in the
gulag still
no you shouldn't but shockingly enough
dave i don't know if you remember i uh i
went through this whole big offensive
truths um on twitter after twitter
accepted elon musk's offer just to kind
of test the waters i mean i was saying
all of it and i didn't get a ban i
didn't get a suspension i didn't get
anything which was shocking i think to
me
along with everyone else and i got to
tell you if i were
if i were thinking who has the most
oppression points here i would have
thought the gay man
way way way more oppression points than
the hispanic woman so that kind of
throws me for a loop but certainly you
don't belong in the gulag for stating
something that is a complete fact well
not only did i state something as a
complete fact all i stated was that
jordan peterson was suspended he's the
one that said the thing that got him
suspended although uh
nick there are biological differences
between men and women are there not well
well the crazy thing is that i did a
movie in 2007 called an american
an american crime
and uh i did it with
elliott page i suppose because the
person that i did it with no longer
exists and
elliot page played my daughter which is
a heck of an acting feat because he was
very believable as my daughter and so
now i don't even know if i can mention
that movie anymore because i might get
suspended it's uh
and if you look it up if you if you
google an american crime it actually
lists elliott page as having starred in
the movie which is
i don't know it's like 1984 they're
erasing the history that never existed
this is the new reality shut up or
you'll be suspended you know i did note
that this week because the only thing i
could really remember ellen page from
was the x-men movies so i quickly did a
google search we did it live on the show
and it said that elliot page was in the
x-men movies and it's like
she was a girl at that time i don't want
to get lost in all the pronoun drivel
and we'll probably get booted from
youtube while we're doing this um but
you know it's like should they have put
the artist formerly known as ellen page
that would make more sense than saying
that elliot page was nick circe's
daughter
[Laughter]
well it's it's hard to get your mind
around but you know we're just obviously
we're not intelligent enough to be
leftist these days
uh ezra you are a gender pronoun expert
what do you make of uh this nonsensical
situation where people are getting
banned over just basically saying true
things and really to sarah's point that
they they randomly pick who and when
they're going to exercise it so
occasionally when sarah's trying to get
away with stuff they'll let you get away
with it and then they'll suddenly take
you out for you know screenshotting
someone else the asymmetry or
inconsistency of it
you know what it's it's easier to debate
the insanity of the censorship and the
pronouns and the dead naming and
misgendering
uh it because it's clearer because we
see the outrageousness i am worried
about what the new ceo of twitter
promised a few years back his name's
parag agarwal and he said when it's not
really about freedom of speech
it's about
um
attention what he meant by that is
who will we
put
your eyes on and who will we hide from
your eyes let me say it another way
i think brag aggro all twitter instagram
the metaverse
it will be uh come soon
that you can dead name and misgender and
be as politically correct as you want
and feel free and no one's gonna ban you
it's just that prague agrawal will not
let anyone see that
you can call it shadow banning so i
think we're moving to the point where
twitter will not ban you
uh you will think you're talking but
you're just shouting into an empty
theater because prague agrawal has given
all the attention of twitter to his
favored viewpoints
this is probably the last moment
where we will see the censorship in real
time we will move to a place where we
don't even know we're being censored and
and we're not conscious of it and we
think we're free but no one's listening
to us other than maybe a few hand-picked
people that's much more terrifying to me
i hate to tell you ezra but i think we
might be on the other side of that
already i mean i think the level of
shadow banning and manipulation and
promotion of certain ideas and
depression of other ideas
i think we're so deep in that that we
may have already crossed the rubicon
that you're worried about yeah i mean i
just don't think that anyone's going to
be banned they'll just uh be hollering
into a into a box and where no one else
is and
and when you can no longer see what
reality is when you no longer have any
direct communication with world because
every single thing in your life is
filtered through a handful of big tech
companies i i don't know how we operate
in that world um i'm terrified by it and
i don't really want
perag agrawal mark zuckerberg or the
others being godlike and i that's what
they want i think when you've got all
the money in the world and all the power
in the world
you're changed from a mere mortal into a
would-be god and they want to control
everything i'm scared of that yeah i
mean when you think about the fact that
zuckerberg did all of this craziness
with facebook i mean anyone that's seen
the movie all of the backdoor stuff and
all the pumping the money into elections
and all that and now he's the one that's
guiding us into this metaverse that they
want to put all of us in i suspect he's
not going to have his kids in there but
put the rest of us in there but i want
to ask you guys a philosophical question
because for me this week when when this
suspension happened what twitter does is
they say to you if you want to get
unsuspended you basically have to admit
your fault you have to admit that you
did something wrong and click a button
that verifies that you admit you did
something wrong and then they give you
12 hours uh where you're suspended my
feeling was that i i was debating
whether i was going to click it or not
and then i thought okay well let me
click it because then supposedly you
will have access to your direct messages
so that i could alert other people such
as you guys about what had happened so
we could get some eyeballs on it so i
did do it i felt horrible when i clicked
the button i really did it was it was
kind of gross having to do it um and i
am now back on twitter because i i felt
i want to bring the fight to them jordan
peterson has taken the opposite approach
and you guys know in what high regard i
hold him and i think you guys do as well
he's saying i'm not deleting my tweet i
am not going on there and uh back on
there and who's gonna blink first what
do you guys think sort of
philosophically or personally about that
that decision of do you go always and
fight in there in their arena even when
you know it's a fixed game or do you
blaze new trails trails elsewhere nick
what do you think
well i've actually done that you know
i've only been suspended once or twice
but it was that you know and both times
it was like some tweet i didn't really
have that much invested in and it's like
okay whatever you know and i did it but
what it reminds me of is what the
january 6 defendants are being put
through in many cases they are pleading
guilty to crimes that they did not
commit and then they have to come before
the judge and say things like i now
believe joe biden was legitimately
elected and i was wrong to go to the
protest at the capitol on january 6.
they're kind of making them do these
public confessions of their guilt which
they don't really believe but they have
to do it so that they you know can get a
lesser sentence or something it's very
sinister and it it
you know it's it's it's part of what
they're trying to do in in silencing
their opposition and shutting down any
descending opinion and it's insidious
and i think it's going to grow i'm with
ezra i think it's going to get worse
sarah what do you think about the uh the
sort of ethical quandary and what do you
do do you fight on their territory or do
you just leave with your integrity
intact
yeah i mean i think it does depend on
what the actual uh tweet that is you
know the offensive tweet was if you want
to stand on principle which i understand
why jordan is doing what he's doing um
but it is it becomes really difficult
when obviously this is a power play that
twitter is is using and nick mentioned
the january 6th defendants we also saw
it during covid where you had judges who
you know were coming down on at least
here in dallas the judges coming down on
salon shop owners for opening when they
were supposed to be closed down and they
went through court and what the judge
said was you must admit that you were
wrong you must admit that you did
something wrong and you will get a
lesser sentence um and so you know you
see this used all the time in this power
played bow down and you will submit to
us or else so it does it feels gross
when you actually follow through with it
but to your point dave i mean i do think
that there is value in taking the battle
into the arena and staying there um
because unfortunately there aren't uh as
many trails as we would like right now
that you can blaze a new one and so it
is what it is at the at this time and i
do think that there is a lot of merit to
just staying in the arena and fighting
where you're at i also want to add on to
ezra's point earlier about shadow
banning
i think they're also um they're going to
protect the narrative at all costs so in
some places they're going to shadow ban
in other places they're going to do like
what they did to the missouri senate
candidate eric greitens when he came out
with that rhino hunting ad which you
know say what you want if you think it
was a distasteful ad but what twitter
did was they said that it violated the
rules but they added a sensor that you
could still view the tweet and view the
video because they found it to be in the
public's best interest now why do they
find it to be in the public's best
interest because there's an election
going on and they want this guy to look
bad because they want him to lose so
it's gonna be twitter is protecting the
narrative at all costs whatever that
might mean if that might mean shadow
banning that might mean well you
violated the rules but we're going to
let people see it anyway because it we
think that it helps our cause whatever
that may be they are going to control
that narrative at all costs yeah and the
broader point i guess more than anything
else is there's a bunch of people
uh who we don't know who they are you
know we sort of have a sense of who this
uh the ceo of twitter is now or whether
he's in charge or not we don't know
because he's kind of gotten into it with
elon but it's basically a bunch of woke
activists that are running this whole
thing nick let me give you the last word
on this one because you mentioned
january 6 your new movie is about the uh
insurrection i guess we can call it and
so why don't i give you the last word on
on this
yeah you can find the movie at
capitalpunishment.locals.com
and it shows what uh what is being done
to
private citizens who've never been
arrested for anything before in their
lives who never even went in the
building and how their lives are being
destroyed by the by the judicial system
it's it's definitely punishment by
process a lot of these people don't
they're not rich people they don't have
250 000 laying around to give to an
attorney to mount a vigorous legal
defense and their basic their lives are
being destroyed and going back to the
rules that uh we were talking about the
the rules are meant to be
capricious and arbitrary they're meant
to be things that you can't understand
that don't make sense because they're
the they're the controllers of the rules
they own twitter they decide what the
rules are and they can violate their own
rules whenever they feel like it so you
better be careful and that's the sort of
uh climate that we're we're trying to
communicate in right now they want you
to not be sure about what you can and
can't say because at any moment they
could just go okay not that
nick i don't know if you can see it on
your end but underneath your name there
we put fake insurrection expert i felt
that that was the best way
that we could describe you and don't
worry ezra and sarah we have special
ones for you too you're going to find
them out in just a moment real quick let
me talk to you guys about real estate
agents i trust you know buying or
selling a home is already one of the
most stressful things you can do and it
can be 10 times worse if you're not
working with the right agent generally
speaking our homes are our biggest
investment that's a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
founded by my good buddy glenn beck they
work with only the best agents in every
market they do their homework talking to
every agent before inviting them to join
their network and here's a big one guys
they only work with full-time pros no
part-time or inexperienced agents their
team makes the introduction and then
follows you through the buying or
selling process to make sure that you're
satisfied the agents they work with have
long track records and are the best
sellers in their field they're part of
this audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
just go over to
realestateagentsidetrust.com and provide
them with some basic info they'll
contact you and make an intro to a
preferred agent in their town and then
like ezra perhaps you can flee canada
and move to the free state of florida
sounds pretty sweet doesn't it my friend
[Laughter]
yeah and housing prices couldn't be
higher there than in canada so much
inflation up here but it's not just the
weak economy it's we don't have the
civil liberties that you do down there
dave and um i guess i see a lot of
canadians who can move are just getting
out whether it's freedom of speech
or people who don't want to be in a
country where the prime minister can
seize their bank accounts
with no legal process because they had a
peaceful process protest outside of
parliament
there's terrible things going on to this
day
a grandma who was one of the organizers
of the trucker convoy she's in prison
today
right now even months later because she
took a selfie with another trucker and a
policeman in ottawa said that was a
violation of
some
anti-mischief provision she was arrested
and flown across the country she's been
in prison for nine days
for taking a selfie with another trucker
dave i'm not exaggerating that's what
they had a hearing about that on tuesday
that civil liberties count
more than the money stuff does dave
yeah well look i know you're not
exaggerating which is why we spend so
much time on this show talking about
canada and people you mentioned your
prime minister people may remember
justin trudeau this is just a couple
months ago
there are canadians who still continue
to choose to not get vaccinated
it's fellow canadians as well
when people are seeing
cancer treatments
and elective surgeries put off
because beds are filled with people who
chose not to get vaccinated
they're frustrated
when people see that we're in
lockdowns or
serious public health restrictions right
now
because
the risk posed to all of us by
unvaccinated people people get angry
and
we have put forward many many different
measures to encourage to reassure to
incentivize to educate
to cajole
to
remind people that it's never too late
to do the right thing
the reason i wanted to throw to that
video even though it's a bit old
obviously is because it sort of
illustrates the point that everything
this guy says is a lie always in the
quest of gaining more power ezra i know
we're all sort of in our own little
bubbles all the time but do you know
anyone in canada that truly supports him
believes him to be an authentic person a
someone who is a good leader as jordan
peterson often says the man simply
cannot say one simple sentence of truth
yeah i think that
he was elected last fall with the lowest
percentage in canadian history that was
still able to form government now it was
a minority government but he's being
propped up by the socialist so he's
actually the least popular prime
minister in history by that measure
uh seven years ago he was fresh and cool
and handsome and he had a famous last
name and he was very woken he's got that
way of talking ladies you know and
and
there were a lot of reasons why he
connected with people but a few of them
have fallen off for example he posed as
the great friend to visible minorities
and new canadians but then all the
photos of the black face came out and
people realized that that was just a
sham
and then he poses as a feminist but then
it came out that he sexually assaulted
rose knight in in the town of creston bc
and said to her later oh i wouldn't have
done that to you if i knew you were
someone important a reporter so he's a
fake feminist but he accuses you of
sexism
he's a fake
uh friend to minorities but he's the guy
in blackface everything he accuses you
of is what he himself is doing did you
hear him say those who choose not to
have uh the injection
he claims to be pro-choice he claims to
be the
he tells americans come to canada for
your abortions if if you can't get them
down there but
only if you're vaccinated americans can
come up to canada to exercise their free
choice over their bodies
unless they're unvaccinated trudeau
isn't just a liar he's a projector of
his own uh
flaws onto you i think canadians are
waking up to once you see that you can't
unsee it once you see that he
tricked you you can't unsee that thing
well speaking of things i can't unsee i
keep seeing these videos of klaus schwab
from the world economic forum all over
uh you know mostly on twitter but all
over the online world you don't see them
ever on mainstream media and the world
economic forum is basically this group
this globalist group that is putting
leaders in all of our countries justin
trudeau was one of their young proteges
here's a video from klaus schwab at the
world economic forum
waves of lockdowns and
stresses
of finding work or returning to
workplaces
have even amplified
the existential and often silent
mental health crisis
so what should you do
you are calling for the international
community
to safeguard vaccine equity
to respond
to copy 19
and prevent
future health crisis
nobody will be safe
if not everybody is vaccinated
sarah the reason i wanted to throw this
yeah that was exactly that was a threat
that's that was exactly my point the
reason i wanted to throw to this video
after the trudeau thing is it seems to
me that all these people have left
and i mean this the democrats these
world economic all they have left is
that we need them because things are
horrible they're going to get worse and
they're also telling us they're the ones
that are going to make it worse in
essence i mean it's extraordinary isn't
it
it really is it's also extraordinary
that you know you get called i'm going
to be really careful with my words here
dave uh from just for you for for the
sake of your youtube here um
it
i'll i'll state a fact here klaus schwab
wrote a book in 2020
it is called the great reset you can
look it up on amazon in which he laid
out
uh exactly
what it would look like if you used a
crisis like covet 19 which is what he
wrote about these are all
facts
and you used that crisis that pandemic
to create a new world no i'll say a new
global alliance uh and the only way that
they know that they can do that is by
instilling fear in people and at first i
think they found it to be a little bit
easier than it is now because you know
people's loved ones were in the hospital
they were sick we saw all of these
videos coming out from china at the
beginning of people literally dropping
dead in the streets and nobody knew why
i mean there was reason for some
americans to be alarmed and to be
fearful
now all they have is this vaccine that
by the way won't prevent you from
getting sick or going to the hospital
but they're still going to threaten you
that if you don't get it you're going to
be left behind it is it's mind-boggling
that they can't give this up but as we
know uh once you get that power you're
not going to relinquish it you're just
going to continue to want more and more
and more it's just crazy to me that this
is happening right under everyone's
noses and i'm still called a conspiracy
theorist for saying they've literally
laid out that they were going to do this
and now it's happening
why is anyone shocked i know that's
almost part of it that it all happens
those of us that are paying attention
see it and in some ways that makes other
people
think we're even crazy or something like
that uh ezra i should mention that uh
your uh we put on your lower third
journalist without air quotes because
it's so refreshing for me to be able to
call someone an actual journalist that
is your special lower third for today uh
nick uh did you see this video earlier
this week where the biden administration
official who of course is a former
blackrock guy was saying that if in
essence we don't go to war with ukraine
and save the liberal world order then
everything's going to collapse that's
sort of directly connected to this isn't
it this idea that we have to you know go
to these wars that we don't declare and
we have to pay more at the pump and
everything else to save the liberal
world order wouldn't that have been like
an alex jones thing a couple years back
right they're saying the quiet parts out
loud now and what you're seeing is that
with even with the covet stuff that's
still going on and in la county they're
bringing back masks for indoors uh
they're never you never are boosted
enough
you know
the screen actors guild union has uh
reinstituted masks on set at all time
whether
and you have to be vaccinated and
boosted in order to work and what i
think is that all of these people in
these uh positions that have been put
there like gavin newsom like uh
like uh trudeau they are not
they their allegiance is not to their
constituency their allegiance is not to
their voters their allegiance is to this
global liberal order that they all want
to participate in and they want to bring
every nation under the sway up and i
know that sounds like a big sweeping
pronouncement but that's what i think is
going on
gavin newsom really
isn't in danger
from his voters because
they've changed the electoral system in
california so that he really can't be
removed by the voters and that's why so
many people like you and i dave have
gotten the heck out of california and
got gone to some place where you at
least your vote means something your
vote doesn't mean anything in california
because the vote the uh politicians in
california like newsom don't have to be
scared of what you think of what they do
don't worry nick i'm not going to tell
people where you're under underground
bunker that you're reporting from right
now is that's right i'm the insurrection
guy i'm waiting for the fbi to come
after me it's like
why haven't they come and get me yet it
would make a great ending to the movie
oh it would make a great ending to this
youtube show too i mean that would be
the perfect moment oh my i hear
something
um well really what you're talking about
there is sort of that we can all see a
conspiracy in front of our eyes but the
thing is it's not really a conspiracy we
found this video this is from about a
year and a half ago this is the prime
minister of the netherlands basically
talking about how the countries that are
in power how they have to basically fund
the media so that nobody can figure out
what they're doing you need to free
press
at these moments to be able to explain
to the people what is really happening
but that costs money so one of the
police i have is big business here in
davos don't put all your money in the
internet advertising make sure that our
newspapers our news outlets also our tv
stations also in the future will be able
to pay sensible and and real
salaries to our journalists to be able
to do this i believe it is crucial
sarah
you work at the blaze i work with the
blaze you work at a place that is
independent no one's telling you what to
do what to say etc etc it is not
government funded by the way the video
we just showed you that was from rebel
news which of course is ezra's outfit up
there in canada for as long as ezra
remains in canada but
this idea that governments should be
funding news
completely insane huh
yeah i mean i think uh china would agree
uh north korea would agree um russia
would probably agree i remember the good
old days when uh media and lawmakers at
least here in america pretended to care
about a free press whenever you know
president trump would utter one mean
word about them and they'd be screaming
about freedom of the press or he would
ban
one reporter from one media outlet while
allowing other reporters from that same
media outlet to enter the briefing room
and they were screaming about how
freedom of the press was under attack
now we're just talking about having
state-run media and uh just like the
communist party of china and everyone's
like oh yeah that seems like a great
idea there's no conflict of interest
there it's all about protecting the
narrative it just is like the social
media companies that we are talking
about twitter facebook mark zuckerberg
uh perag
they have to protect the narrative at
all costs they know that which is why
they need the journal the journalists to
do their dirty work for them is it's
just sick ezra can you talk a bit about
what's going on in canada right now
relative to this bill that's being
pushed that i think has actually been
signed already where pretty much
everybody is going to you're going to
have to now register and they'll be able
to control what you can and can't say
and of course you already have the cbc
which is basically in bed with trudeau
and the liberals so you already have a
state-run media in canada
yeah you know you'd think
inflation price of gas groceries
whatever would be the most important
thing to a government today but trudeau
actually it's censorship and control of
the internet he has four different bills
going through parliament some have
already passed um they're going to
regulate the internet like they regulate
like
tv stations and radio in canada which is
very strictly
um trudeau has been paying the media
hundreds of millions of dollars
but only the media that quote he trusts
that's the word he used trustworthy
media which means his media he's
colonized them um
he's introduced a journalistic license
called the qcjo qualified canadian
journalism organization and it's his
staff that will determine whether or not
you're qualified and if you're not
qualified and obviously we will refuse
that status you will be
his next bill is to require facebook
google
to boost the qcjo the qualified licensed
media in the rankings and d boost so
it's not just that google and facebook
have their own algorithms that are
biased trudeau's bill would require them
to introduce his biases into the
algorithm to silence his critics like us
and to promote the ones that he trusts
it's a licensing provision one last
thing dave it's not just the government
money and in canada
99.9 of journalists now take government
money 1500 media companies i didn't even
know there were that many in canada are
on the dole there's maybe 10 that aren't
including us
but google and facebook are now spending
hundreds of millions of dollars directly
subsidizing legacy media also in
australia in canada that's another thing
you have to be a qcjo licensed trudeau
journalist to get that big tech money
but if you're an independent journalist
but suddenly a third of your money is
coming from google and facebook and a
third of your money is coming from the
government
you're not an independent journalist
anymore at least not on anything
touching the government or big tech
journalists no longer work for their
viewers they work for oligarchs we
should start using that word oligarch
here why should we only call ukrainians
and russians oligarchs you don't think
bezos is an oligarch you don't think
zuckerberg is an oligarch someone who
has money and power and wants to rule
the world and to hell with the little
people and democracy we have our
oligarchs too
nick uh to that point i mean having just
done your movie capital punishment you
know we go through this absolutely sham
ridiculous i don't even want to call it
a trial i don't know what you can call
it other than a clown show this january
6 hearing which it's basically done
already and nothing came out of it there
was this pretend moment that they
claimed trump tried to grab the wheel of
the car i mean it's all so stupid
everyone thought it was a joke except
mainstream media they really loved it
doesn't that kind of prove the point
that uh ezra is making here
absolutely i mean i loved that idea that
trump fought his way through the back of
a limousine through the through the good
movie man to get to the driver yeah it
made him look even better than i thought
he was i didn't know he was like some
kind of superhero
but yeah i mean i'm old enough to
remember it being taught in school about
pravda and about soviet propaganda and
how you know state-run media is a bad
thing they taught me that in history
class in high school and now i think
what's happening is that these
journalism schools they churn out these
kind of
brainwashed people i mean khrushchev
said it back in the 50s we're going to
march through your institutions and we
will take you over without firing a shot
and that's what they've done to these
journalists and so many of them it's not
like some grand conspiracy they've all
been educated to accept this idea that
it's okay to take money from the
government and then
say what the government wants them to
say and i it's it's gone so far that
it's really it's going to take a long
march back through the institutions in
order to change things and to get these
journalists back to to the point of
actually reporting the actual news
rather than just being mouthpieces for
whatever government they serve well
speaking of pravda we have our own
browser right here in the usa it's
called the new york times and check out
this headline from the new york times
this week here's a doozy the rise of the
far right latina representative myra
flores is one of three republican
latinas vying to transform south texas
politics by shunning moderates and often
embracing the extreme now of course
mayra flores won her district about two
weeks ago it had been under democrat
control for about a hundred years it was
mostly about the border so of course now
she's far right uh sarah
we've got a special lower third for you
you are our far right latina expert
today
uh but first let's show a little video
of myra flores responding to this
nonsense
with that far left bias the new york
times has
should you and i consider the new york
times a legitimate news organization
congresswoman
they're not
like i said they don't know us they have
no idea who we are and who our culture
you know
they just do not represent our community
and i feel that you know no one really
cares about the new york times
especially in my district we're worried
about health care worried about the cost
of gas the cost of food that's what
we're worried about not the new york
times or none this nonsense that's
happening in washington latinx none of
that we're focused on the issues that
really matter to
to the american people and i'll refuse
to you know give them any attention they
claim that they're for immigrants i'm an
immigrant i'm from mexico and yet all
they do is hate me
all right gonzalez
gonzalez far-right latina expert do you
agree with flores
oh 100 i mean look i have been saying
for years now that the democrats uh
would
they would experience a
high levels of loss of uh hispanic
voters because the as as always they
over play their hand they want to make
it all about illegal immigrants as myra
pointed out
they they claim to be for immigrants but
only the ones who have gotten here
illegally so what that does it's slaps
in the face to all of the people who did
it the right way who know that there is
a legal process and who respect this
country enough to go through that legal
process she also said you know on top of
the border her issues are god family and
country these are things that
traditional hispanic families value very
very highly a lot you know most of them
are catholic uh they are very very
pro-life they are very very staunch in a
lot of these social issues that
democrats have just gone so far left and
so far extreme that hispanics are like
i thought i was with you guys but it
turns out now that you've shown your
true colors i actually don't think i
align with you guys anymore i've said
that it was going to happen for years i
think that it took being under the
leadership of trump for them to realize
how well they had it you know they were
working the economy was good the things
that actually mattered to these hispanic
families they were all good they saw
that happen then they see the switch to
joe biden and they saw all of the
extremes that they were going to the
left was and how it did not align with
their traditional family values and i
think hispanics have really had enough i
hope that that's what we see in november
um i really do dave isn't there
something kind of beautiful about this
because they're showing us exactly what
they did to trump and how they'll do it
to any of us to call her far right then
if you read the article and i i actually
read a new york times article i mean
basically all they say is you reference
the far what they mean by far right is
that she's for a border and then she
goes to church that's what they meant by
far right so it's sort of like oh
remember when they used to do that to
trump and he he wasn't even a big
church-goer nick i surprise i guess none
of this is surprising to you like you've
seen this game before
yeah
well when uh you know she says that her
slogan is god family and country god and
family are the first things the leftists
want to get rid of because that the only
thing they want is country they don't
want god or family because those things
make your allegiance to someone
other than the state
and so this is
this is not an accident that they're
going after her
because she is a turncoat to them she
they think they have these ethnic tribes
that are supposed to be democrat and
anybody that turns against them and goes
the other way is now the enemy and to
call her far right
common sense is far right
to to today's left it's like she wants
to have a border where you can control
who comes in and out well that's any
everybody should want that that's common
sense you don't leave your door unlocked
in case somebody wants to come in your
house and get something you want to
control who comes in and out of your
house i wonder if they're going to leave
the gates open at their gated community
and just say it's it's really
discriminatory for us to keep people out
of our gated communities we need to open
the gates no they're not going to do
that
by the way i don't want to brag but it
was about five years ago that front page
sunday new york times called me jordan
peterson thomas soule and milton
friedman the leaders of the alt-right so
you know
at least at least she's in good company
uh i'm gonna give ezra the last word
here but uh nick can you remind
everybody because i'm thrilled that you
launched your new movie on locals uh i'm
honored and thrilled actually can you
just remind everybody where they can get
it yeah two ways to go there
capitalpunishment.locals.
because that's the name of the movie and
you can also subscribe to my amazing
feed at
nickcercy.locals.com where you'll get a
lot of a lot of tasty treats in addition
to the movie
there you go ezra bring us home on this
friday from canada
sure you know what there's nothing more
racist than a liberal dealing with a
minority who's not following the party
line
uh i mean myra flores
uh trudeau's right hand man gerald buds
called me a jew he implied i was a nazi
the the racial hatred and the use of the
n word for clarence thomas would shock
uh a cleagle a grand klu klux klan boss
um
it's it's all for power they don't
really mean it they never meant any of
it they never meant their belief in
freedom of speech other than as a
temporary tactic to take an institution
i think
i love myra flores and i i i love the
fact that more and more minorities are
not following the script handed to them
by the left that's part of free speech
too dave thanks for your hospitality
today
all right to my fake insurrection expert
my uh
far right latina expert and my
journalist without quotes uh i've
enjoyed having you guys on we'll do this
again and have a good weekend guys i'm
gonna finish up for a couple minutes
without you but thanks a lot all right
thank you thanks dave see ya
all right people i feel that that was a
a solid ending to the week and i have a
real surprise right now for the three
gentlemen in this room
do you know what i ordered for lunch
daphne said to me this morning what do
you want for lunch
and i said you know what it's been a
good week
they will eat the chick-fil-a
there is fried chicken with all the
sauces
all the sauces polynesian
chick-fil-a sauce honey mustard barbecue
it's all down there right now
so i have nothing else to add because
connor's going to end the show right now
because he loves that fried chicken see
you on monday
you